we begin with breaking news a magnitude
7.8 magnitude 7.8 earthquake has struck
southeastern region of turkey the
epicenter was pazarchik but the Tremors
were felt in several provinces
the mayor of San Luis Province says at
least five people have died there
Tremors reportedly lasted about a minute
and it's understood some buildings were
damaged a fire has also broken out after
the earthquake in karaman marash
province
for more on this I'm now joined by
Cinema casolu who's monitoring
developments from Istanbul Cinema what
more do we know at this point
uh well uh Muhammad this is one of the
biggest earthquakes that has happened in
Turkey as far as we see that it has been
felt everywhere from south southern
coastal city to Northern coastal cities
by the Black Sea from Damascus to Beirut
and uh we have been speaking to people
in the area to our colleagues and to our
friends as well they have been telling
us that this is the worst earthquake
they have ever seen uh as some would
remember in eastern city of Elizabeth
there was also an earthquake nearly two
years ago and the experts have been
discussing that there are some fault
lines that are moving in that turkey
needs to be very careful about potential
earthquakes in the region and now some
experts on Turkish media are discussing
that this is one of uh this is actually
what the expected earthquake is but so
far we are hearing that some buildings
are collapsed especially the old
buildings in the arbucker and in Karama
and the casualty reported as per the
governor is five people for now but the
impact of this earthquake is seen and
stopped in many cities not only the
epicenter of kahama maharash and those
cities for instance
is a very crowded city with a hosting
not only Turkish citizens but also a
huge amount of Syrian refugees in Turkey
we know that a Turkish president also
made out some calls and currently
Turkish interior minister is speaking
live in the region and some
International Help might be necessary
for the rescue works but the earthquake
is very new and we will be seeing new
reports new information about the area
but I must also say that uh the the the
impact of the earthquake is felt very
strongly in Northwest Syria and uh uh
from the eight organizations uh working
in Northwest Syria we are seeing we are
hearing that the hospitals are full of
injured people so
um apparently the the building quality
everything is very important when it
comes to earthquake uh for for two kids
that has suffered many earthquakes in
its recent history uh this is also one
of the very important times but Muhammad
the worst thing about this earthquake is
the weather condition for instance since
yesterday schools have been shut down in
the Turkish capital Ankara in Istanbul
Istanbul hasn't even seen much rain this
year but it's snowing flights to the
region have been canceled and there is
snow in gazian diversity where many
people felt the earthquake in the
strongest way which is very close to the
epicenter uh mama is like 28 30 km so
the weather conditions are not well for
the citizens and for for for civilians
to be outside there is snow outside
there is rain outside and even let's say
the buildings are not damaged people
will not be staying of course inside
those buildings and this is a tough time
for turkey this is a very tough time for
the citizens living in the country all
the people so we will be following the
developments and following the courts by
the Turkish authorities uh some uh some
centers they report that this is a 7.8
magnitude earthquake through kids
disaster and management agency says this
is 7.4 but uh going above seven and this
is one of the most critical earthquakes
that turkey has experienced so far
Muhammad all right that's Al jazeer solo
thanks so much for all of those details
we'll be checking back with you for more
shortly